mario paul donc toujours sur l'île sous
les bombes aux russes la ville n'est pas
officiellement tombée en revanche les
russes contrôlent depuis plusieurs
semaines la ville de personnes qui dans
le sud bonjour gulliver craag vous êtes
rendu dans la région que se passe-t-il
sur place
alors je suis en ce moment à kryviy rih
qui est dans la région de dnipropetrovsk
et je suis allé à la dernière ville dans
la région de dnipropetrovsk avant qu'on
traverse pour aller dans la région de
personnes les russes affirment contrôler
toute la région des personnes ce n'est
pas exactement le cas quelques villages
sont encore aux mains des ukrainiens qui
affirment avoir repris le contrôle de
certains villages ces derniers jours là
où j'étais à hélène houde au losc je
peux confirmer que il y à des batailles
tout le temps je suis allé hier et ce
matin et on entend des tirs au loin on a
vu aussi certains éléments
d'infrastructure qui ont été touchés
quarante pour cent de la population d
hélène aux que pourtant selon le maire
est resté sur place malgré des frappes
qui ont eu lieu sur la ville même mais
surtout ce qui se passe et ce qu'on voit
à zelenov c'est l'arrivée de personnes
qui fuient la région des personnes par
la ville derrière ce même où il est
devenu presque impossible de partir mais
des villages dans la région des
personnes certains fuient les villages
contrôlée par l'ukraine à cause des
batailles intenses et d'autres fuient
les villages contrôlé par la russie et
là c'est extrêmement difficile les
russes ne laisse pas les gens partir en
voiture pour la plupart ils ne laissent
pas les hommes partir mais nous avons pu
rencontrer ce matin un couple qui venait
juste arrivé à zélé nous donne ce qu'il
était à peu près huit heures et demie du
matin ils nous ont raconté qu'ils sont
partis à 3h30 du matin pour ne pas être
vus par les russes espérons que les
russes dormait encore à cette heure là
et ils ont traversé les champs ils ont
fait trois heures et demie de route à
pied en courant parfois ils ont dit ils
ont dit avoir vu des missiles par tien
passé au dessus de leur tête pendant qu
ils fuyaient et au moment où ils sont
arrivés à zélé noz que temps que dans
une sécurité relative
tous les deux ont éclaté en larmes
c'était un couple d'une soixantaine
d'années je pense est à là ils ont dit
qu'ils n'avaient pas pleurer depuis le
début de la vaz y ont jusqu'à ce moment
où enfin il se sentait en sécurité
relative et là c'était un soulagement
mais aussi ont sauté un traumatisme
extraordinaire chez ces deux personnes
merci gulliver craag correspondant
france 24 ans en ukraine où la guerre a
commencé il ya soixante et onze jours